bonjour et bienvenue sur France 24 et
sur Radio France Internationale nous
sommes à New York en marge de
l'Assemblée générale des Nations Unies
et notre invité aujourd'hui est le
président de la République du Niger
mohamed Bazoum et avec moi pour cette
entretien Christophe bois-bouvier de RFI
monsieur le Président bonjour bonjour
monsieur le Président au Mali et au
Burkina Faso les djihadistes contrôlent
dépend entiers du territoire le G5 Sahel
c'est fini Barka n'est parti donc une
question se pose en raison de cet
environnement sécuritaire est-ce que le
Niger est en danger est-ce que ça
pourrait être le prochain domino à
tomber
la situation
dans l'espace de nos trois pays sur le
plan sécurité s'est dégradé c'est
incontestable
est-ce que pour autant elle aura pour
effet de
faire ce que vous dites que le Niger
aussi tombe
je ne le pense pas je le pense notamment
que nous avons depuis longtemps eu une
situation
différente du Mali et s'avère aussi a
postuler différentes de Burkina Faso
en plus de ce qui caractérisait notre
situation
et qui déterminait un rapport de force
bien déterminée entre nous et les
terroristes nous avons désormais une
situation plus confortable à cause de la
coopération que nous avons noué avec nos
partenaires extérieurs et la France
notamment la présence de barkham sur
notre territoire et son engagement aux
côtés de notre armée à la frontière du
Mali
renforce nos positions et créer une
situation beaucoup plus favorable il
faut aussi dire que lorsque vous
comparez notre situation aujourd'hui à
ce qu'elle était en 2019 en 2020
c'est sans commune mesure nous avons
renforcé les effectifs de notre armée
nous avons renforcé les capacités de nos
soldats nous avons réalisé des
acquisitions en termes d'équipement qui
font qu'aujourd'hui nous avons une armée
beaucoup plus solide et donc beaucoup
plus apte à faire face
à la situation même dégradée
d'aujourd'hui au Sahel alors depuis le
mois de novembre et la mort de trois
civils nigériens lors d'affrontement
avec l'armée française à Tera il y a
épisodiquement des manifestations
anti-françaises à Niamey il y en a
encore eu une il y a quelques jours
alors vous avez souvent dit que ce
sentiment anti-français n'était pas très
important au Niger mais est-ce que vous
ne vous voilez pas la face sur une
réalité que l'on voit ailleurs dans le
Sahel
moi je parle du Niger je sais pas ce qui
se passe ailleurs au Sahel au Niger
moi qui suis élu de façon démocratique
et
qui est pour ambition de faire en sorte
que
notre partie reste au pouvoir le plus
longtemps possible
je fais très attention à mon opinion et
je me garderai absolument
d'être en décalage avec elle si ce que
vous devez je serai le premier à le
sentir et je serai par conséquent le
premier
à avoir l'attitude que me commande mes
intérêts
le phénomène dont vous parlez est un
phénomène
surtout propre aux réseaux sociaux
du moins au Niger
je ne pense pas que ce soit une
préoccupation des citoyens nigériens
quand je sais les problèmes auxquels ils
sont confrontés et quand je sais que
leur plus grande demande vis-à-vis de
l'État de leur assurer la sécurité
quand je sais tout cela je me dis que
être contre les Français ou contre les
Américains n'a pas de sens au demeurant
vous l'avez constaté une manifestation a
été organisée le dimanche passé et elle
a réuni moins de 500 personnes donc ça
veut dire que c'est davantage un
phénomène
médiatique que
une opinion vraiment ancrée au début de
cette année monsieur le Président vous
avez annoncé que des discussions étaient
amorcées avec certains djihadistes alors
concrètement est-ce que cela donne des
résultats sur le terrain est-ce la
raison pour laquelle il y a une certaine
accal apparemment dans votre pays et
est-ce grâce à ce dialogue que la
religieuse américaine Suède Tennyson a
été libérée le 29 août dernier sur votre
territoire oui nous avons affaire à des
jeunes bergers qui sont engagés dans
[Musique]
ce phénomène qui qui est plus de
banditisme
au fondement alimentaire qu'autre chose
et
leurs agissements ont un grand impact
sur la cohabitation entre les
communautés
puisque nous ne pouvons pas nous
adresser à eux pour en faire des
partenaires politiques avec lesquels
nous pourrions avoir une discussion
politique des niveaux élevé nous avons
privilégié les contacts à la base
qui associe des représentants de
communautés pour expliquer dans le cadre
de la mission de la Haute Autorité à la
consolidation de la paix que le plus
important c'est d'abord que le
communauté
s'entendent entre elles qu'il n'y ait
pas de tension entre elles nous faisons
ce travail-là mais excusez-moi monsieur
le Président pour obtenir la libération
d'une religieuse américaine il faut
parler avec des chefs djihadistes non
nous n'avons pas parlé avec les chefs
c'est tant que
il est né au sens où vous vous
l'entendez
nous avons parlé avec des sous-chef
avec qui nous sommes en contact
permanent pour leur expliquer que ils
n'ont aucun intérêt dans ce qu'ils font
et ce travail là nous le maintenant et
il donne il ne donne pas des résultats
spectaculaires mais il crée des
conditions d'une accalmie entre nous
entre notre armée et eux d'une part mais
surtout au sein de communauté on sait
vous l'avez répété ici à New York que
l'éducation pour vous est fondamentale
là vous parlez de faire revenir des
jeunes dans le droit chemin mais avec la
démographie galopante que connaît votre
pays on sait que beaucoup de jeunes sont
plus tentés peut-être par une traversée
de la Méditerranée ou rejoindre le jihad
que fait-on vraiment pour les retenir
au-delà des beaux discours
au Niger nous n'avons pas de gènes et
qui sont candidats pour traverser la
Méditerranée on le sait depuis longtemps
cela c'est du tout simplement à le faire
niveau d'éducation il faut donc en
urgence agir pour promouvoir l'éducation
et faire en sorte qu'elle bénéficie aux
populations qui en ont été le plus exclu
que sont les populations pastorales ça
c'est un investissement qu'il faut
envisager pour des résultats à long
terme dans l'immédiat il y a beaucoup de
choses à caractère économique à faire
pour fixer les populations et il y a
enfin la sécurité à leur assurer et il y
a surtout le rapport de force qu'il faut
créer contre tous ces acteurs de cette
violence
qui ne prospère que parce que justement
ils peuvent faire certaines choses de
façon impunie et pour cela il faut armée
il faut un état et il faut des
institutions c'est ce que nous faisons
au Niger en juillet dernier la CEDEAO a
levé les sanctions économiques et
commerciales contre le Mali on sait que
vous vous étiez plutôt pour le maintien
de ces sanctions mais juste après cette
décision de Clémence les militaires
maliens ont arrêté 49 soldats ivoiriens
présents au Mali en les traitant de
mercenaires est-ce que ces sanctions ont
été levées trop tôt est-ce qu'il faut
les rétablir
je ne peux pas répondre à cette question
je déplore le fait que ces soldats de
Côte d'Ivoire étaient arrêtés par les
autorités du Mali je trouve ça
totalement absurde
les propos à l'occasion de nos réunions
de la CEDEAO du président Ouattara
résonne encore dans mes oreilles il
parle du Mali avec beaucoup d'affection
et il a été pour beaucoup dans la levée
des mesures
de sanctions prises par la Cedeao alors
que vous étiez plutôt contre vous je
constate aujourd'hui
qu'il est payé
par l'intitulé de ce qui ont tiré profit
de cette décision d'élever de l'embargo
à laquelle le président Ouattara avait
grandement contribué il s'estime trahi
oui je considère qu'il a été trahi moi
aussi
monsieur le Président depuis le départ
de barkhane du Mali ce sont les forces
maliennes les FAMAS avec la société
russe Wagner qui mène le combat contre
les terroristes alors est-ce qu'ils font
mieux que tout d'abord que la France et
notamment est-ce que ils sont présents
est-ce qu'ils agissent dans le nord-est
qui font frontalier avec votre pays
la situation dans la région de Ménaka
c'est totalement dégradé depuis le
départ de Berkane
depuis la fin du mois de mars
les terroristes ont conquis des
territoires encore plus vastes ont tué
plus de personnes et ont créé une
tension entre les communautés comme cela
ne s'est jamais passé
je
les forces armées maliennes serrées à
Manaka
avec leur supplétif russe
mais je constate que cela n'a pas
empêché que la situation se dégrade
davantage vous utilisez le conditionnel
parce que vous êtes pas sûr qu'elle y
soit non elles sont bon elles sont à
elles sont à menaces
on dit qu'elles sont avec les Russes ça
j'utilise le conditionnel et qu'elle
soit là-bas avec les Russes ou qu'elles
soient sans le Russe la situation est
menacé dégradée la situation à Gao aussi
est en train de se dégrader et jamais la
tension entre les communautés peuvent
étoilettes n'a été aussi vive
qu'aujourd'hui et il y a des risques de
massacre
entre ces communautés à grande échelle
je ne pense pas que c'était ça
l'objectif de faire partir le français
nous aurions pensé que après tout ce
qu'on a dit des Français et
on ferait autre chose que ce qui peut
donner lieu à une dégradation de la
situation telle que nous l'observons
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous pensez que
les le drapeau djihadiste pourrait
bientôt flotter sur Ménaka et sur Gao
c'est très probable
en tout cas je suis convaincu que le
IGS
[Musique]
compte
attaquer maintenant est-ce que ce sera
pour y rester ce n'est pas leur mode
d'action que de rester dans des
localités importantes comme menaca et
ils n'ont jamais eu de vocation
administrée quoi que ce soit mais ils
sont militairement capables d'attaquer
Manaka est-ce qu'ils sont capables
d'attaquer Gao aujourd'hui non je ne le
pense pas mais autour de Gao ils ont
réalisé de grandes avancées alors comme
le Mali le Burkina Faso est en grave
difficulté face au djihadiste et
pourtant vous venez de recevoir à Niamey
le chef des militaires puccistes le
colonel d'amyba vous envisagez un accord
de défense entre vos deux pays et c'est
à dire cabamaco ce sont des mauvais
putschistes et à Ouagadougou de bons
puccistes
non
vous savez nous avons traité les
militaires maliens comme nous traitons
les militaires burkinabè en ce moment
souvenez-vous
quand c'était le président bandao
c'était les militaire qui était au
pouvoir et nous avions de relations tout
à fait normal avec eux selon ce qu'ils
ont fait le deuxième coup d'État et
qu'ils ont décidé que les élections ne
sont pas une priorité qui se sont
écartées des engagements notre vœu
aurait été que nous copions de la même
façon que nous le faisons avec le
Burkinabè ils sont nos voisins il y a
une situation de fait
que nous avons pris en compte et qui
commande justement que nous coopérions
pour que nous nous protégeons
mutuellement que nous nous renforceions
mutuellement et que nous nous
renforcions contre nos adversaires qui
sont les mêmes et si les puccistes de
Guinée Conakry maintiennent leur
calendrier d'une transition de 3 ans
est-ce qu'il faut envisager de lourdes
sanctions de la CEDEAO comme le
préconise son président en exercice le
président m'balo de Guinée-Bissau ils ne
sont pas lui au moins ils ont une façade
maritime
les sanctions les plus fortes qui
peuvent être prises sont des sanctions
justement de fermeture de frontières qui
les concernent qu'en partie et des
mesures à caractère monétaire qui ne le
concerne pas du tout c'est parce que les
militaires guinéens savent cela qu'ils
ont le comportement que nous observons
depuis toujours qui consiste à être un
tant soit peu coopératif avec la CEDEAO
comme si ils n'ont jamais été membre ou
qui n'entendent plus un être membre mais
des sanctions sont possibles et quels
seront probablement prises si le
dialogue que nous avons engagé contre
eux ne veulent pas
merci monsieur le Président de nous
avoir accordé cet entretien et merci à
vous de nous suivre sur nos deux chaînes
France 24 et Radio France Internationale
[Musique]